we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p you know i wonder
do the does my audience call other shows
to complain about me because so many of
our callers call me to complain about
other people the san antonio troll
regularly complains to me about things i
didn't say that he heard on other shows
troy york regularly calls in to complain
about other people and that's what he
did unleashing a brutal and completely
unintelligible attack on kyle kolinsky
of secular talk
i don't know what troy's talking about
and i don't know why he's calling me
about kyle see if you can make any heads
or tails out of this or figure out
how this even has anything to do with me
uh david
um
kyle kelinski is a propagandist
and a liar
who keeps
attacking companies that are resisting
unionization and starbucks and amazon
two examples okay
are companies that would not exist
through massive unionization
and this is the goal of kyle kalinski he
wants to see
starbucks destroy
more empty storefronts in communities
across this country
i mean listen quite frank i haven't been
to starbucks in 20 years i quite frankly
think the coffee's a disaster so i i i'm
half kidding i understand the jobs
component but uh i'm no big starbucks
fan maybe kyle shares in that i don't
know
um he attacks amazon
despite the great services and products
that it's able to deliver okay
and kyle kalinski is basically a
undemocrat ignorant
socialist
a undemocrat ignorant socialist
and i don't know how you ignorant
leftists like kyle kolinsky
continue to lie and propagandize on the
internet
kyle kalinski i guess the same way troy
does i don't know like yourself and jane
cougar
and sam cedar
also what's playing in the background
but it's like my show is always playing
in the background of these calls
uh hate this country our
anti-american you say nothing about no
one not one of this
unionization attempts against starbucks
can amazon
ever complain about
the workers in taquerias
um that are mostly funded by drug
cartels in mexico
immigrant business you never talk about
immigrant business and indian
restaurants being
unionization yeah i mean
i don't know what troy york is talking
about and i don't know why he's calling
me about kyle kalinski and i don't know
what kyle said
but
please call kyle i mean is it why do you
have to call me just call kyle tell him
what you think and uh
i don't know man it's a it's very very
strange to call me we're going to have a
great bonus show for you today we knew
that vehicle fatalities were up during
the pandemic but we didn't know why
we now know that excessive speed due to
less busy roads played a role in that we
are going to talk about wind and solar
which now are responsible for 10 of
global energy production that's still
not a massive number but it's a big
change and things are going in the right
direction there we are also going to
talk about another one of the
problems that has to be dealt with for
long-term space travel for humans you
know in the past we've talked about the
radiation component needs to be figured
out a lot of radiation when you travel
through space
the other issue is bone loss and there's
a new study about it i want to talk a
little bit about cycling and some things
that are connected between those things
and a lot of uh energy now going into
how do we deal with the bone loss issue
and that's something that's already
being studied
very very interesting stuff an eclectic
bonus show for you today you can sign up
and get instant access at joinpacman.com
the coupon code wow 22 will save you a
bundle
and i really look forward to seeing you
on the bonus show last reminder
for today i'll remind you again but next
tuesday april 19th we will be doing a
live viewer town hall at 6 pm eastern
time it will be open to everybody
members will have their own
way of getting in touch with me during
the town hall
and um it's going to be streaming only
on our second youtube channel the pacman
live youtube channel so make sure you're
subscribed there it's free
it's free to subscribe it's free to
watch it's everybody can call in but if
you want priority handling during the
time town hall
become a member at joinpacman.com i'll
see everybody on the bonus show and then
back here tomorrow